good morning believe nation my name is
Evan Carmichael my one word is believe
and I believe that entrepreneurs will
solve all of the major problems of the
world
so today's message is be patient over to
you simon Sinek
[Music]
i talked to so many smart fantastic
ambitious idealistic hard-working kids
and they're right out of college they're
their entry-level jobs and I'll ask them
how is it going and they'll say I think
I'm going to quit and I'm like why they
say to me I'm not making an impact I'm
like you know you've been here eight
months right they treat the sense of
fulfillment or even love like it's a
scavenger hunt like it's something you
look for my millennial friends they've
gone through so many jobs they're either
getting fired I mean it was mutual or
they're quitting because they're not
making an impact or they're not finding
anything they're looking for they're not
feeling fulfilled as if it's a scavenger
hunt love a job you find joy from is not
something you discover it's not like I
found love here it is I found a job I
love that's not how it works both of
those things require hard work you are
in love because you work very hard every
single day of your life to stay in love
you find a job that brings you ultimate
joy because you work hard every single
day to serve those around you and you
maintain that joy it's not a discovery
but the problem is the sense of
impatience it's as if an entire
generation of standing at the foot of a
mountain they know exactly what they
want they can see the summit what they
can't see as a mountain this large emove
Abul object that doesn't mean you have
to do your time that's not what I'm
talking about take a helicopter climb I
don't care but there's still a mountain
life career fulfillment relationships
are journeys the problem is
this entire generation has an
institutionalized sense of impatience
and do they have the patience to go on
the journey to maintain love to feel
fulfilled or do they just quit and on to
the next dump and on to the next ghost
and on to the next I'm a big fan of
maudlin success I'm a big believer that
you can shortcut your path to success by
finding what other people have done to
achieve that success learning from them
and applying it to your own life to your
own path to help you get there faster I
love finding shortcuts I love finding
hacks I love finding all the
productivity tools and team and
everything you can do to climb that
mountain faster but the Simon's point
there is still a mountain there's still
a lot of work that has to go in it's
working smart and working hard it's not
just one or the other to go and
accomplish your goal if you look at my
YouTube channels example since we're
watching here all together you have made
5,000 videos for this channel 4,000 of
them are public and a thousand plus of
them are not their practice videos or
demo videos or test videos I sucked at
the start go back and watch my first
video and look how bad it is
somebody recent left a comment at one of
my videos I recorded five years ago and
she said oh my Evan look at how far
you've come five years later you sound
and look different in so many good ways
and that's awesome to hear and also
really frustrating you know I am mostly
the same Evan that I was five years ago
my belief system my values maybe I've
learned a little bit more gaining a
little bit more experience but why am I
so much better now on camera than I was
way back then because I practiced what I
had four or five years ago compared to
what I have now the difference is five
thousand videos you know that one
thousand videos that haven't been
published those trying and errors and
failing on those thousand videos that
never got released are more than what
most people ever create most people who
start a YouTube channel they'll make 3 4
or 5 10 videos and quit because it's too
hard because it's too challenging
because they don't want to climb that
mountain but they don't want to put in
the work
we're here the thousand videos that
never saw the light of day and four
thousand more that are going now can you
get there faster than me sure you're
looking at Alex look at Lily who've been
helping me on some of the videos they
are already better than when I was when
I first started they're already better
than I was maybe a thousand videos in
you can get there faster than me you can
model success maybe you also have just
more natural talent you can rise the
ladder faster than other people around
you if you have more natural talent if
you want success if you have a deep
passion for what you're doing you can
get there faster but it's still a long
road you still have to be patient you
still have to put in the work I think
that's what people often get too
frustrated by is they want the immediate
results they want the immediate success
and they don't get it then they quit and
so understanding that this is a deep
passion of yours is something that you
want to commit potential the rest of
your life to doing because you care
about it so much then expect to suck at
the start expect it to take a long time
expect to work on trying to improve your
efficiency and productivity and skills
and resources to get there fast as
possible but expect to be committed and
stay patient and if you are whether it
takes you 100 videos or 5,000 videos or
more with the equivalent in your
industry
you'll get that so the question of the
day today is I'm curious about your reps
I'm curious how much are you putting
into your business how much you
practicing daily to get better at
whatever skill it is that you have that
you're bringing I'm curious about your
schedule leave it down the comments
below I'm excited to what you guys have
to say I also want to give a quick shout
out to latina thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book your one
word it really really means a lot to me
and I sincerely hope that you're
enjoying the read so thank you guys
again for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is I will see
you again tomorrow morning for another
shot of espresso
more expresso give me
so a bunch of group of really brilliant
psychologists in the in the field of
expertise research I have sat down and
tried to figure out how long do you have
to work at something before you become
really good right and the answer seems
to be it's an extraordinary consistent
answer in an incredible number of fields
and that is you need to have practice to
have apprenticed for 10,000 hours before
you get good so every great classical
composer without exception composes for
at least 10 years before they write
their masterwork Mozart tensor is
composing at 11 but he's composing
garbage at 11 I mean he doesn't produce
something great until he's 22 or 23
concerto number nine I think 271 if I
asked you how long did it take you when
you were doing this job before you felt
comfortable and good at what you were
doing 10 years old is it same with me
when I Vincent got to be consistent
finding in it it's really important
because it says that we are far too
impatient with people when we when we
assess whether someone has got what it
takes to do a certain job we always want
to make that assessment after six months
or a year or and that's ridiculous you
know the kinds of jobs we have people do
today are sufficiently complex that they
require a long time to reach mastery and
what we should be doing is setting up
institutions and structures that allow
people to spend the time and effort to
reach mastery not judging them
prematurely patience is for the
impatient that in fact when you're
getting started in your in-laws are
making faces at you and you're not sure
if you're going to be able to pay the
rent and you don't know why you're
living in Brooklyn to begin with and
you're going to have to move back to
Florida it's easy to say you know what I
need to go faster to pick up these
scraps and pick up these scraps and
sometimes what that does is it gives you
the foot up to get to the next level but
sometimes what that does is it just
makes your scrap collector and that one
of the things that we see when we look
at the work of people who have put
really big ideas into the world who have
built online platforms right is that
they got there by being patiently
impatient or impatiently patient
whichever way you want to just
that if you look around at the blog's
you read or the people you respect
online or the organizations you want to
work with the myth of the overnight
success is just that a myth that you
know the much-vaunted Twitter was a
failure a complete failure for two years
nobody used it and if they took the
mindset of well if it doesn't work in
two weeks we got to go do something else
you never would have heard of it you
know China is a very special place and
if you look at the big tech companies
apples done very well Microsoft hasn't
lost too much in Google's you know lost
a lot it was quite a bit of variation
despite all three of those being
talented long term oriented companies
and when you look at Apple one of the
amazing things is when they did the
iPhone they negotiated and talked and
built relationships for six years before
the iPhone was allowed to come to China
so from 2005 2011 and that's a lot of
patience and now that's one of their
largest markets in the world for the
iPhone and so what we take away from
that is a sense of great patience so it
may be soon that we have a license in
China or it may take a couple years but
we're going to be very patient and we're
looking forward to a time you know a
decade or two decades from now when the
Chinese middle class will want and
embrace the kind of content that we have